good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday
wow wow
wow to you miss paris queen oh yes
i am wearing a very uh hot
exclusive everything rich everything
exclusive shirt
uh from this boutique on my favorite
street in champs-elysees
uh it's called uh sarah you're so
parisian like is this emily in paris
sitting here
or is it claudia in a shirt with eiffel
tower it's claudia
and her fast fashion from zara i told i
tried to warn you guys
that like my wardrobe was being taken to
the next level and you didn't believe me
here claudia fast fashion fast food
fast five yes name of today's episode
don't forget it
okay um yes my shirt is from zara and i
just wanted to warn everyone this is
just like a foray into my new wardrobe
like
you're going to be [ __ ] quaking so
get ready because i'm really sick and
tired of putting up these pictures every
day in the morning shows and everyone's
commenting
jackie you like him and myself am i
invisible
stop there are so many days right never
never thickening glowing hair
no but it's really important to note who
chooses and edits the photo
jackie who gets approval of which photo
we use
hardly i don't really get an update with
you know edits and stuff
but things have to move in groups no
today's my day like the comments are
going to be quaking the comment down
they're going to be quaking for you no i
just thought this was such like a
delight they're going to play
claudi and perry no i'm claude dean in
paris
100 so thank you for noticing my new
blouse i actually really appreciate it
no it's so sick like so cool we'd love
to see
swipe up link will be amazing we really
love to see a new blouse on the show
because we're constantly wearing the
same blouses
so important to have a constant rotation
of blouses
no matter what field you work in i
really believe that like when i go
shopping my first stop is category
tops blouses always blouse lousy vibes
only
lousy vibes only so thank you for
bringing this
energy to the show today you look
elegant as well um thank you i'm just
like wearing some
like a cool girl outfit no i mean like
that outfit is i mean that jacket is
like the most sickening jacket it's also
sisterhood of the traveling jacket
because i wore it once and not only did
it fit me like a glove
like i actually think it was made for me
and like it should be mine when did you
wear it
in newport remember we were like all
swapping outfits because we were just
like really girls on a trip the best on
the trip when like oh wait no my bag
would go great with your office can i
borrow your sunglasses no and everyone
was being so generous that trip like
bringing their finest things like want
to borrow my scarf if you want to borrow
my bag
and we all looked our best because we
were working as a team a hundred percent
and the
funnest fact about this jacket is i got
it on etsy no when i tried to find it
afterwards like i didn't even know what
to search i should find the etsy seller
i bought it from i'm sure she has some
other
he or she has other great items do you
mind yeah no no problem
because i love supporting local
businesses on etsy i bought it for
stagecoach a few years ago because i
just felt like i was looking for like a
harley-davidson vibe which i'm
always looking for a harley-davidson
vibe and i found one
i'm so overjoyed for you it's really one
of my favorite spring jobs i'm jealous
so i feel like we're both like you know
acknowledging the space that we're in
and we're feeling pretty good about it
even though like the second i left my
house today like feel like you know i
took
obviously some extra time to get ready
today like i was just feeling myself
this second i start walking rain yeah
rain
rain it's a rainy day as you guys can
see but i don't know it's like so moody
and it's not like annoying rain that you
know means you can't leave your house
it's just like a little trickle it's
april showers you know what it kind of
makes me want to do
what i would love to know if you could
guess what i'm thinking go to the movies
well no but you know we actually can
yeah yeah maybe i should do that that's
a good idea
no but something more like in my house
called a vibe okay keep going read
no keep well yeah keep going um
i don't know what do we do aside from
take a bath make it chili
oh yes i gotta get the ingredients but i
think i'm gonna make a chili today we
should do a virtual chili cook-off today
i have been trying i actually have some
can i make a chili with ground turkey
yeah because i have ground turkey like
that's in my fridge that's because i was
like i'm gonna cook with ground it's
actually probably delightfully light
i'm going to make a chili with ground
turkey today well that's exciting ask
ben for his recipe like it's so worth it
i will i will concede
my loss and finally ask the winner for
those wondering what we're referring to
because maybe you're new here
head over to patreon.com morning toast
we did a chili cook-off over the summer
when we were all renting a house
together
and it was tight well it wasn't really
tight but it was fun it was
fierce it was jackie vs ben i was um one
of the judges
i was alan brown like from food network
oh yeah you weren't a judge you were
host i was a host and then olivia zack
and margot
who all loved chili were the hosts i
mean the judges
yes and it's such a great vlog the great
chili cook-off
was a great chili you know what i think
i'm gonna watch the vlog and then start
my chili and i feel like that'll get me
into the chili spirit yeah
um some things key ingredients that you
need that you want to make sure you
have uh broth is so super like stock you
know i do have
chicken broth and i have vegetables okay
very important which then says
okay i could also go to the store i feel
like i'm actually gonna be out and about
a little bit today i have some errands
to run
like this week i'm accomplishing all the
errands that i've put off for 365 days
and by the end of the week like i'm
gonna have my whole to-do list checked
off that's
such a thrill i'm so excited for you
what i have um on my list that i i'm not
ready to do is like i have
got to clean out my closet like major
haul like donate stuff reorganize and
i'm just i'm so not even there like i'm
so not doing it but it's getting worse
and worse like i'm overflowing onto my
chair and the floor like
it's so annoying yeah i've been doing
bit by bit recently so right now
everything fits in the closet
but i don't have one hanger to spare and
after my retreat i do plan on like going
to zara and doing what you did because
you spoke so highly of it
so i will be honest i'm just like two
weeks behind you and you know me like i
cannot
just like like something i have to like
be obsessed with it until i ruin it like
i've been on the app non-stop fabulous
app even though like i still have a
problem with how they photograph their
photos
i photograph their items because like i
probably would have gotten more stuff
but like these girls are just like
contortionists wearing a tank top like
it makes no sense yeah
um but the app is pretty good okay well
i'm really excited to join you on the
journey
no like sarah and at some point in the
next couple weeks like we have to go to
the hudson yards one
okay that was like a fun daytime
activity yeah we should be vlog shop
till we drop
i actually hate shopping till i drop i
i'm always shopping till i drop because
i just can't stop
no but i shop till i drop like from the
comfort of my own bed online no but like
we need just a day pound the pavement
and then we like get drinks and dinner
after them
it's a full last day i just like hate
physically shopping but the idea of a
drink
i i would do it yeah i would do it so
that's what we'll be up to
other than that i just feel like this
week has just been
so i don't want to drink it like fast
oh not for me i feel like every day i've
woken up like what day is it
so finally we're we're down we're going
downhill
and for that i'm grateful you know when
you're really excited for like your
weekend plans the week seems to go by so
slow
yeah well that's me with my retreat well
i'm like so excited for my weekend plans
and the weekend like the week just
couldn't be going by faster for me i'm
super grateful no for me i'm just sort
of like sitting around waiting for the
retreat so every day just feels really
long
that's like crazy like you're just gonna
be like at this retreat and i'm
literally gonna spend like the next 10
days just like i have so many plans in
the next 10 days like and they all
revolve around like blacking out
okay i mean everyone has their own
journey
so true and no one's is better than
anyone else's
so true and everyone should do what's
best for themselves and i believe
wholeheartedly that that's what's best
for you so so beautifully sad you don't
even need to retreat
i am the guru you already sound like you
just got back from it
oh my god i hope i get so many more like
positive mantras
yes and that i can share with the group
oh my god we are so that way in need of
manifestations over here that way we
all get to go on the retreat i think we
oh
jackie and i have been quoting that
victoria justice video if you don't know
it like just
educate yourself google victoria justice
we all no but you need the context of it
because like there are always these
rumors that like victoria justice was
the star of
victorious but like ariana grande and
the other like liz gillies like
they were so popular like amongst the
cast and crew so talented and so
talented and it was like it was victoria
justice's show but like
there were many stars on that show and
there was always these rumors of
victoria like being like you know diva
whatever and there's this one video that
kind of like really makes you believe in
the rumors because they're all doing
like an interview all the girls
and they're talking about how they just
like sing all the time in dressing rooms
when they're talking they're just
singing
singing and then the interviewer was
like who do we think sings the most and
a lot of the cast members were like
probably ariana and everyone's like yeah
probably ariana grande and then out of
nowhere victoria justice goes
i mean i think we all sing like a lot
and it was just like so territorial and
it was so [ __ ] funny
so territorial watch a video yeah so i
can't get that like
trope out of my head no because like we
all really like that trope
we we all all really do so
check it out that video will live in
your hand rent free you're welcome
you're welcome um and other than that i
didn't really do much of anything
yesterday i'm like trying to even think
like
what i did yeah i didn't do much either
but i did start a new book last night
called i was anastasia by ariel lawhin
who wrote
codename helene so oh your favorite
anesthesia romanov
plus like one of my favorite books is
author i think i'm in for something good
even though
because i watch lazar i know that this
anastasia imposter spoiler alert
is not anastasia romanov and just like a
crazy person
so i think the book like makes you begs
the question like was this the real
anastasia and like i know the answer
right but still i i want to know more
about this crazy it's obviously more
interesting that it's
not her no it's crazy it's crazy yeah
i'm gonna read before we were strangers
this weekend cause i'm having a very
peaceful
both turned up and peaceful weekend out
in the country oh man i'm really excited
for you
and i just um think that's what is best
for me i think that's what's best and
you know once you're done like you could
listen to the redheads episode about it
yeah i think you would enjoy it totally
this way i would have read
three redheads books wow nothing to see
here it was still such a great book
and what was the other one you read my
own oh i feel like there was one more
um were there any colleen hoover's layla
have you read lately no
you might have a rarity not not a
redhead spot what
that's crazy yeah you might like layla
you might like husband secret
okay so ch ch check it out um
we have the real housewives of new
jersey recap in the tv recap segment
boring episode but i can't be mad
because we were coming off the heels of
like three like eight plus episodes i
can't be mad i can't be mad so
i think we could just i think we could
just jump right in without further
um do here are the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and yes jackie that may be true but
today's episode has a very important
sponsor it is our patreon
program so you love the toast five days
a week we turn out content for you
non-fucking stop but if you want more
there's an app for that
it's patreon.com your morning toast or
you can download the patreon app
in the app store and it is our
subscription service so this show is
free it'll always be free but if you
want five extra episodes well i
shouldn't say always but we'll see
um if you want five extra episodes from
us a month podcast episodes vlog
episodes
for 7.99 you can sign up at
patreon.comtoast
get more content from us get access to
our exclusive one and only last
remaining facebook group
wonderful community by the way and get
access to all 200 plus of the episodes
that we've already done
so you will literally have content four
days four days we've been doing
patreon for like the last since you
started this yeah
three years and so if you log on and
join now you get access to like every
podcast vlog we've ever done so
check that out we have the just the
chili cookoff's on there so it's so
worth it
there's drunk get ready with us like
there are so many gyms
maybe you and snitch okay it was
actually a really fun night we went to
the squeeze concert after we drunk got
ready
when we have like a plan yeah i know it
was actually the perfect situation
but i was so hungover i was hungover as
well
um so patreon.com the morning toast
great way to get more content and
support your favorite podcasters
thanks love it okay first story big
story of the day jlo and a-rod
officially call off their engagement
they say quote we are better as friends
they issued a joint statement that said
quote we realized we are better as
friends and look forward to remaining so
we will continue to work together and
support each other on our shared
businesses and projects
we wish the best for each other and one
another's children out of respect for
them the only other comment we have to
say
is thank you to everyone who has sent
kind words and support
um so i feel like we knew this but i
guess this is like the official
announcement but like they like put out
an announcement and then like
got screwed and then and like went to
like were photographed in a like house
in dominican republic
yeah like saving face and then they gave
it a few more weeks and they were like
no no forget it we're done yeah i mean
it's crazy just to like kind of take a
step back and realize like
madison lacroix's um power yeah she
definitely did this
and one well actually a-rod did it i'm
not going to blame him no but like
the spotlight that southern charlotte
put on the infidelity that a-rod i think
had been up to this whole time
made jayla look like an [ __ ] yeah she
couldn't ignore her she couldn't ignore
it yes
um also it is really sad because like
their kids were like
first of all upset like j those kids
were obsessed with a-rod a-rad's kids
were obsessed with j-lo and the kids
were obsessed with each other it was
like a
ideal blended family and of course a-rod
had to go and [ __ ] it all up
yeah no i am sad for the campers in this
like when i read that same and they're
like
at respect for our kids it's like
anymore i'm like oh my god the campers
um and like bunk is quaking no the bunk
is like literally sobbing like they're
all just like it's like the day after
when all their parents leave on visiting
day and like they're all just crying
yeah but they're also splitting up the
bunk now because
some campers have left camp so they need
to condense the boat that's terrible
you know yeah i mean of course this is
not surprising
but what i do think is weird is like
they made an announcement that they have
an exclusive announcement coming and
then like an hour later so that they
were breaking up so it was just like a
weird
way to announce it's not like you're
announcing like you're running for
president like it was just very formal
oh that is weird
and a-rod has been like putting up these
weird kind of like
shrine like stories like he has this
like counter with like all these
pictures and candles of them
and their families and like and he's
just like taking videos of it it's like
literally a seance it's the weirdest
thing ever like i encourage you to go
look at his story
really weird he tagged jlo with a heart
yeah yeah like they're just trying to
really make it seem like they're on good
terms but if i was jlo like i would not
be on good terms with this man
no i don't need any more friends
you know i'm so popular like i need a
solid businessman beau
who's gonna like not
bring [ __ ] around yeah and that's all i
need i'm sure she's
good on friends i think probably the
reason why we are personally like taking
this so hard is because
first of all we like them so much as a
couple and two like this was really the
infrastructure around which we built the
businessman bow
and for me like this was such a good
pairing because he was a businessman bow
and the thing about businessmen beau is
that
you go for them because they're not
gonna like they're supposed to be solid
they're supposed to be solid and
trustworthy and honest and good
and he [ __ ] let us down and like he's
business member but he is also like a
professional celebrity athlete so like
that does make it complicated
he's not your typical businessman though
but i also feel like we're taking it so
hard because like
we really built like our biggest ship
for them like norwegian cruise side
ship and like now we just have this huge
ship sitting there
what do we do with it dormant dormant i
don't know
dormant as [ __ ] we're gonna need a new
couple and to take over that
big-ass ship okay can i tell you you
know what our enterprise is actually
sort of like
in the red because we have a few major
ships that are sitting dormant
him in kanye we are literally that scene
in the greatest showman when his fleet
of
trading vessels in the south china sea
like that's us
literally wait also not that i'm even
gonna like have a ship as big as i had
for jayla and a-rod but you know which
couple i'm like
really into kravis and then megan kelly
well i like them both yes but this is
what i like previously didn't understand
but now i'm feeling like after watching
a lot of their videos i really
understand
i don't know shayleen woodley and aaron
rodgers
they did like i don't know if they did
this partnership with disney but they
have this like
long interview of them sitting on a
couch in the middle of a disney hotel
and they're just like being really cute
like they are wow i'm happy for them
that you have turned this corner
you know like i didn't understand it at
first like i didn't see how they were
compatible in any way but
after watching a couple videos i think i
have had a come to
jesus moment okay well that's good news
i don't know if they're
worthy of the one of the biggest ships
in our port no not not that fast
someone's getting promoted a speed boat
yeah
a speed boat for sure we always start
small but you're right we have two mega
yachts the kim and kanye ship
and the jlo and a-rod ship that like are
just completely
dormant completely completely it's
devastating so i i
we're either gonna need new couples to
ship or we're going to have to promote
some of our mid-size our mid-size
vessels but i
don't really like have any kind of like
you know motivation for those mid-sized
vessels they're mid-sized for a reason
yeah and i don't want to put too much
pressure on them by giving them a ship
that they can't steer
you know maybe we give that ship to like
oprah and steadman you know
yeah someone who's just like so [ __ ]
solid that we don't ever have to worry
about
like kevin bacon and kyra sedgwick
i'm gonna pass on that okay like um
goldie hawk and kurt russell but like
sure you can have our ship like it's
first like i literally wouldn't
recognize you if you came and saw me on
the face on the street like
totally yeah no we'll work on on our
fleet
we we shall work on our get back to us
circle back
okay well our next story um is m
in is i'm french now um oh are you
inspired by my blouse
i am or should i say my blue i'm
constantly inspired by you
um our next story is a follow-up to some
news from yesterday former bachelor
colton underwood is filming his own
netflix reality show after coming out
colton underwood former star of the
bachelor is getting his own reality show
at netflix variety is learned the
project which is crazy
look at netflix no that's like a big ass
show
no like is he that famous i don't know
or is that show that good
the project was just currently in
production so no way to say whether or
not it's good yet
is an unscripted series with multiple
episodes numerous sources tell variety
describing the project as focusing on
underwood
living his life publicly as a gay man
netflix declined to comment on the
project
um i have a few thoughts i've been like
marinating on this whole story like it
was
all i could think about yesterday
because like it's literally the only
thing that happened
um and i have a few thoughts one i
actually think the concept for this show
like does sound interesting
and if i didn't have this like problem
with colton like maybe i would have
watched it
but the more and more like i look into
this and like read into it
i'm like i'm just like feeling more and
more disturbed like on behalf of cassie
randolph you know
okay it must be really hard to see
most of the world like celebrating
someone who you feel like victimized by
and like no one's even like really
talking about it like i was looking on
twitter just to see like a lot of people
were like is this the guy who like
had a restraining order put on him like
because people are like content
and people in the gay community who are
really excited about this for obvious
reasons
um aren't like real like bachelor fans
and i don't think they know the extent
of
she's just like being celebrated by
everyone and i can just imagine how
traumatizing that is for cassie
and i just didn't think like netflix was
in the position of giving shows to
people who
you know harass and stalk their
ex-girlfriends i just didn't know that
so i'm struggling with that
okay yeah i hear that i saw a really
funny comment on our instagram post
about this like saying holston being
colton is like being his authentic self
like thirst and all yeah no he's always
been so thirsty so this
tracks like selling his own journey
selling his job for you
selling his journey um can we also talk
about
um the carol radswell of it all you sent
me her tweets last night
because carol radzwell like isn't like a
full-time tweeter tweeter like she's so
active on twitter
okay and i saw something come up on my
tic toc and i'm like that has to be a
fake tweet because carol would never
say that so hold on i sent it to you so
she went on like this whole twitter
rampage where oh here are texts
um of things about colton so her first
one that like really rubs people the
wrong way was
congrats to colton underwood but also
what you apply and compete with other
men to go on a tv show looking for love
and you think you might be
gay what about processing that without
involving
oh sorry what about processing that
without involving 25
crews and 25 girls it's a great day for
gay men bad day for young women
and it's like that might be the worst
take on colton underwood i've
ever heard there are different takes you
could take here because obviously that
colton has like a controversial past
that might be the worst take i've ever
heard like sexuality's so
complicated and like he literally
explained how like he literally thought
he was like
fixed when he got the cast as a bachelor
like he thanked god for it like
there's just like that worst take no she
doubled down people are literally
responding to her like
carol this is not it she doubles down he
was dishonest with the producers and
women about his motivation
you can't just disregard that piece of
it what if a girl fell in love with him
and what was her journey about then
don't look at it solely from the man's
perspective there are many women
involved too
now that's like an earnest tweet
assuming that everyone who goes on the
bachelor's like literally head over
heels in love with colton but we all
know like some of them probably
most of them probably didn't even like
like him and just one of the instagram
followers yeah
also a lot of the women from his season
have spoken and said like they're so
happy for colton like all good triple
down
i'm happy for colton to be living his
truth now is anyone talking about
whether abc executives
should be vetting their contestants
better or what the women think
at robin roberts at bachelor abc what's
good
i just i don't even know if i could get
into how bad of a take this is because
it's
of course like many things so layered
but it's like
like coming to terms with your sexuality
is so much more complex you're not
deceiving anyone
and i actually think that's like a
really like bad dangerous take so i just
wanted to share those tweets
because i just didn't see that you know
yesterday like when we were discussing
like
did i think that cal rodswell was going
to be the one like with the weirdest
take on the whole
thing like i never would have expected
that no i never would have expected that
either life is full of surprises
and that's what i love about it yeah
constantly being surprised constantly
being surprised
but in terms of the show does it have a
name um no
not yet and it's still in production so
like it's
there he's literally in new york filming
it now i saw a post that he was like
spotted filming at the stonewall inn oh
i guess that like they're gonna document
the journey of like
in real time like when he comes out what
like people are tweeting like you know
how the reaction is
him actually going to gma yeah i mean
like it does sound like a good show
does it kind of um because for me i'm
like i'm dying to know what's going on
like behind the scenes like how was he
taking it how was he doing
yeah but i just like who was he hearing
from right right
there's a part of me that like just
can't get on board
yeah i stand with cassie randolph okay
cool i i mean i just feel like i
probably just won't watch because either
way
like lack of interest yeah but i i'm
happy for colton
yeah did you also see that billy eichner
video that's like making the rounds that
just did not age well
i don't know what they were filming for
maybe it was like promo for the bachelor
and they had billy eichner on and he was
like
i'm gay you could be gay maybe you'll be
the first gay bachelor it was like
obviously a joke
he's like you should look into that yeah
and colton's face is just like
a journey of emotions like shock aw
defense like it was it was very
interesting layered
like so many things mm-hmm like both of
our hairs lighter yeah
well actually i could use a fresh crop
are you ready for our next story it's
going to take us on a journey
don't stop believing josh richard's
drama
involving jaden hossler and nessa
barrett
explained we are here to break down what
the kids are up to on tick-tock
as far as you guys need to know there
were two kind of like young power
couples
on tick tock jayden hosler
and mads josh richards who hosts the
bff's podcast with dave pornoy
and nessa who's a singer nessa has been
recently making the rounds on the late
night talk shows because she released a
song
that she wrote that she performs with
jaden from the other couple
and they've really been performing with
travis barker so they've been spending a
lot of time together
and i think you all know what happens
next what happens next is that
jaden and nessa are have gotten together
so josh and jayden
are very good friends the two enjoyed
their friendship they were all so happy
in their respective relationships josh
was dating nessa
jaden was dating mads however things
changed when jayden and nessa got
together to work on la dee da
a song the two released on february 19th
amid this the rumors about josh and
nessa breaking up hit social media
following this the news of madsen
jayden's breakup also surfaced online
mads went on to claim that she andrade
that jaden
and she broke up because of nessa she
claimed the two had been spending a lot
of time
following their music release josh broke
his silence on the bff's podcast with
dave portnoy and josh richards he
admitted that he felt upset after the
video for the song was dropped he said
i'm looking at this video and i see two
people i love they're like my family i
would die for them tomorrow i would die
for them now
the possibility even if it's point five
percent in the back of my brain of like
[ __ ] i could lose both these people
that's what made me sad that's what
[ __ ] killed me he further revealed
that he and nessa were on a break when
the rumors about her and jaden dating
surfaced online
and so cut to the chase jaden and nessa
are like a full-fledged couple they've
been paparazzi at all around i like
going to dinner making out like they're
fully together
and mads is devastated yeah and josh is
just kind of you know
being like a dude about it yeah but
they're all very sad
and it's the biggest deal for the world
yeah like
honestly i find myself like really
active in like the tick tock drama
and i just i can't get myself to give a
[ __ ] about these people because
in the in the world of like the tic tac
stars these are all like
with the exception of maybe josh
richards like they're all b-list so like
are they what about i feel like i've
heard about nessa for a while well there
was that drama when she kissed chase
hudson
who was dating lil hutty lil hooty who
was dating charlie to me
that's so funny because on my timehop
yesterday charlie and little huddy's
breakup statements came up i guess i had
screenshotted them
lol first of all hard-hitting journalism
so like for me like a lot of people have
been like talking about on the toast and
like
i plan to and like i'm well versed in it
but like i just don't really care
they're like not my favorite tick
tockers
and honestly i didn't even know who mads
was yeah i'm not gonna lie
i only knew who josh was and i and i
watched an episode of bffs and
he was talking about this but i didn't
know i didn't know about it context i
think i fast forwarded
um and that was probably like the only
part that like people were tuning in for
right
for sure um but he seems like a really
actually great kid
yes and i think that him and mad should
get together duh
yeah but like no no no
what about him and addison i feel like
addison is so beyond the same and
charlie
sure i'm just going off of every tick
tock no but like now then that
complicates it with a little hoodie
is little hoodie still around yeah he
actually released a song
like a machine gun kelly vibe and people
really liked it it's called like vampire
school or something
wow vampire blood kids are wild daytime
vampires something like that
okay well um i don't know the kids have
gone wild they're all breaking out
making up
but we are happy for everyone to find
happiness
i guess yeah sort of these two better
like stay together forever or else
yeah well that's the thing if you're
going to blow up two relationships and
it becomes such a big thing
this is like the similar to like sabrina
carpenter and joshua bassett like they
are still together and like
if at the end of the day like it was all
worth it for true love and they're
married 60 years in the future like you
know in their rocking chairs on a house
in a house in malibu like then it was
all worth it yeah like nicholas shy
vanessa lucia
right exactly great point so with these
two
maybe jayden and nessa are you know the
next oprah and said man 100
and that's the only way that like this
will be as well yeah
yeah totally okay ready for our next
story
yeah actually that's not i'm just gonna
move them around
it doesn't make sense speaking of
relationships kanye wants to date an
artist after kim kardashian
divorce kanye is already thinking about
his next relationship the newly single
rapper wants his next relationship to be
quote with an artist and a creative
person a source tells page six so take
it with a grain of salt
explaining it so they can speak the same
language to each other
but his next partner has a lot to live
up to west has previously declared i am
michelangelo i am picasso
he also told gq i am unquestionably
undoubtedly the
greatest human artist of all time it's
not even a question at this point
it's just a fact so if he's going to be
with another fellow artist
the artist couldn't be the greatest
artist of all time because he fills that
role just like going back to that
statement
um while i don't think it's true i do
think that kanye like
is one of the most influential artists
of our generation in terms of fashion
music
lifestyle design for sure yeah i feel
like
i was ready to agree with him if he said
like i'm the greatest human artist like
right now a hundred percent yeah so like
there's just something lame about like
the greatest artists of right now saying
that they're the greatest artists you
know well you know what like
have confidence in yourself having
confidence because if you don't believe
you're the greatest artist
who will that's so true i know i really
am like the greatest artist of our
generation
yeah so believe it manifest it
and it might come to be it might come to
be i mean as far as him dating an artist
i feel like that's a really
good logical next move for him one so
they can speak the same language as he
says
but also like how are you going to
compete with kim
you know it's not like kim can just go
and date another rapper now
like so i think they both are gonna have
to look outside
because you're not gonna be able to
compare the two because they're both the
greatest in their field so any if you go
to the same field
you're just gonna get someone who's like
subpar but also like as they've grown up
it's actually become like extremely
apparent like how different
different they are and kim is like very
straightforward
very straight edge like you know logical
business-minded
and connie is very like artistic
abstract abstract says what he wants
so i actually do think someone who
speaks the same language they by the
time they got divorced they were
speaking two totally different languages
and i think someone who speaks kanye's
language would be great for him and
someone who speaks kim's language would
be good for her too yeah you know who i
see him with not this person in
particular because she's
in a committed relationship yes i was
literally thinking like
he sounds like the relationship the
source says he's looking for it's like
an elon musk and grimes like we don't
understand genius and an artist
we don't understand it but like they do
well i i'm understanding
like elon and grimes more and more
they're they're legit
like the proof is in the pudding they're
nick lachey and vanessa lachey no
except they didn't like leave anyone for
each other or actually amber heard yeah
no i'm just saying like something where
at the beginning like you just assume
it's another relationship and then all
of a sudden it's otp
i'm gonna give them our big ass vessel
i'm gonna give it to them because i
don't think we ever made a ship for them
no and i feel like in the beginning like
when i saw pictures of them at the met
gala like i was like
they look like freaks yeah well they did
look like freaks of the met gala i stand
by that but you know what i mean i just
like didn't get it at all
no but like i'm i'm getting it and i
feel like kanye sees that and he's like
oh i want that for myself i think he
sees himself as an elon musk
agreed and he sees elon like just we are
so
unlike the same yeah so i don't know of
like all the contemporary artists of our
time
i don't know that many or anything but
i hope that i'm sure kanye knows because
he's like into art you know when he's in
the art world
yeah so i hope that the art world like
sometimes you do need an
artist woman girlfriend businessman beau
artist acquaintance
yeah so i feel this for him me too i
really do that's why are you ready for
our fifth and final story now
it's the final story
yeah instagram launches a test where
users can choose to see likes
so instagram is launching god make up
your mind well apparently their initial
idea of where hiding likes didn't go
over so well like
it wasn't super popular and also my
likes were hidden for one day and then
they came back so they obviously i still
have mine yeah
are all over the place on this issue
instagram is launching a small global
test on wednesday
where users can choose whether to hide
the like counts on their own post or
other people's posts a
facebook spokeswoman said the photo
sharing site which is owned by facebook
inc
said this latest test came after seeing
mixed responses to its experiments in
which it removed likes commonly used as
a measure of popularity that's so funny
because like i saw all the influencers
being like i love this like taking likes
but it's like yeah because you have the
worst engagement ever
but i got no likes i would like that too
i had likes the entire this
entire never lost it i i lost it for not
even a full day
you know that i have many instagram
accounts and girl with no job
does not receive updates from instagram
you know my comments are still
chronological on that account
interesting i can't filter them i never
got the moving text
like i don't get updates on that account
it's crazy anything with moving text
okay i feel that makes me feel better
yeah i've never used it no i'm literally
using like seven versions too old on
girl with no job but then i switched to
claude with no job and she's updated as
[ __ ] yeah morning toast account is super
updated morning toast is like literally
my beta
must be the first account to get a new
rollout from instagram like we get it
the second yeah and for my personal like
i don't get it i feel like i'm on the
back half of getting it which i like
because you know let everyone experiment
first
and then i never had to go from not
having likes to having likes because
once again
i think their intention with not having
likes was that there's less pressure
better for your mental health and people
will
post more if there's likes which would i
actually agree with that philosophy yes
and also at the end of the day even
though like sure they're worried about
our mental health they just want us to
post more that's what it was
but i didn't think i don't think that it
worked well honestly
they just need to make up their mind i
feel like we've literally been talking
about this since we were in our old
studio
yeah they need to make up their mind you
know what likes are integral to the
instagram
ecosystem so just no and if you're going
to like
get rid of them like get rid of them
don't be like well you could turn on
this setting and have it and then this
person could
run that setting and not have it like
yeah nobody cares nobody cares really
like
i make a decision like when i'm going to
my feet i'm not looking how many likes
did each picture get but once in a while
i go to a person's page i'm like how
many likes do they get
you know that's a good way to see like
who has fake followers right but also
i found an interesting on last week's
keeping up with the kardashians when kim
was like my photo's about to hit 4
million likes should i post another one
or should i wait and i was like
you even look at likes anymore no i
actually
like the second we ended last week's
episode i was like i'm so i'm going to
talk about that one scene where kim was
talking about her 4 million likes
because i completely agree with you i
was like i didn't even know people like
took that into account anymore i guess
maybe if i was getting millions of likes
like i would
yeah but i just feel like if kim's not
past like tracking her likes how can any
of us ever be
survive yeah but also and then i went to
kim's photos because i guess like four
million is like a big
you know mark of success for her so i
was just like looking at what her
photos do get and like which ones get
the most and it was i'm sure like the
promotional ones get the least like kkw
beauty and
yeah the kids get a lot and obviously
her like snatcher picks get the most
good that's why she does them yeah um
okay well those were the first five
stories and i feel as though maybe you
didn't need to know them but you're sure
glad you did
hundred percent let's talk about
children's age i mean it was so boring
but my one takeaway from the episode was
that we need to speak to a medium speak
to
that medium i completely agree when i
was in college
i literally put myself on a waitlist for
the long island medium it said
two years okay that was like eight years
ago i have never heard back
well we need to speak to that medium or
any medium like she was so on point no i
know she was freaking everyone out like
i could tell like some of the women but
like margaret was like
not really skeptical and then the second
she was like
uh jan's father like it was just i don't
know i'm
i don't really believe that stuff but i
do think that there are certain people
who can definitely like connect
with it yeah i think it's interesting we
definitely need to speak to a medium it
was nice to see it i think it was like a
good
thing for all the women to be vulnerable
in front of each other
and they're in a good spot these women
the only real tension brewing is between
margaret
and jennifer yeah and it's a problem
it's a problem
because neither one of them are going to
back down no but hopefully
yeah i don't know how they'll move past
it it's not going to stop until one of
them is
off yeah the delores storyline about her
mammogram was really really interesting
because like she's been
like so active in the um like doing
philanthropy for
breast cancer for breast cancer
awareness and she like had forgotten to
get her mammogram then they kept teasing
that she was like hysterically crying
and i thought that like she had gotten
bad news um
and then the the the medium
started out by being like your like
grandparents who passed on like want you
to know like
you're getting news it's something
physical and i was like oh this is when
she cries but then she started crying
about her dog
oh which i totally get totally get
totally
no i thought um it was like a fun
episode to watch nothing much happened
but i just love the women of of jersey
and i'm glad like jackie and teresa like
genuinely squash the beef because i
can't
same and honestly like it was making me
like really hate jackie even though like
i was on her side
i know she was just not handling things
right properly she had
the winning hand hand but she played it
wrong but she folded
yeah yeah like now when i see her and
evan like i do kind of cringe
yeah when she was like i'm gonna be
until daddy loves me no more
just kidding i'm like oh god um but i
did love seeing rosh hashanah
on the real housewives of new jersey
because even though new jersey is a very
jewish state and a lot of them live in
really jewish towns like margaret lives
in inglewood
i think jackie lives in tanafly we've
never had like a jewish moment
and i did like seeing rosh hashanah and
for that like i'm grateful to jackie for
finally bringing you know
the spirit and the rock of rosh hashanah
to the real houses of new jersey 100
it was it was nice to see but other than
that like why was that woman michelle
at the reading are they trying to make
that happen yeah like there was
rumors but while they were filming that
like she was a new housewife teresa's
realtors the new housewife i think that
they were trying to integrate her
um i do think they run out of time yeah
and also like i'm
not buying like at all what she's
selling i also think that like when she
came on they expected like okay she's
selling teresa's house she now she's a
housewife but she got like shut out by
melissa they weren't expecting that
yeah and so she missed like otherwise
she would have been invited to wherever
they went
next right so she missed a few episodes
and now i think it's too late
they're going to glenmaier mansion which
i've been like dying to go to i heard
they have like an amazing spa i know and
i
think i think they allow pups i was like
looking into it a few weeks ago
um and it just didn't work out we got a
name or maybe they don't allow pups
maybe it was one or the other that's why
they didn't work out it was one or the
other
for sure they either do allow them or
they don't yeah
what are the odds um so yeah and really
i have nothing to really say about
jersey i'm not mad that we got such a
bad episode not bad just like boring
because like the last like three or four
have been like
stellar gangbusters so they need to
break and it's fine things turn up on
the boat
but um margaret what kind of ghost
writer has he got
that's a good one
um by the way margaret who is one of our
amazing podcasters here at chosen news
network
released her book this week and we
actually got a shout out on like page
222 or something like that
um her book is available everett's
called caviar dreams tuna fish budget
it's the same name as her podcast
and there's new podcasts coming from a
lot of our tnn shows there's a new
turning out premium content
date night with raven and alexis they
made a huge announcement on their
podcast if you want to check it out
and of course mood with lauren elizabeth
she had
norma kamali on her podcast i saw we
said to her we're like you
will love norma like let's set it up and
i haven't listened to the episode yet
but i'm going to because i feel like
it's really good no it's so good that
you
if you ever need like a kick in the
chihuah de vivre norma kamali's your
girl
uh that's mood with lauren elizabeth and
that is our show that is our show
nobody else's don't get it twisted don't
get it [ __ ] twist it
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the last five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up for the people who are
still listening one thank you so much
and two
our 100 merch is still out so head over
over to shopmorningtoast.com
we had a great launch day and so if you
want to get your 100 merch
shopmorningtoast.com we're also
available anywhere you can get your
podcast
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning toast leave a 5 star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
beautiful stunning smart merch is also
available at shopmorningtoast.com so is
how you dirt merch and redheads merch i
hope you guys have an amazing thursday
we'll see you tomorrow for
friday friday you gotta get down
on friday goodbye goodbye